a boat used to be the only way to get  into this Bay in northern a man even by  local standards boomer sundown Peninsula  is remote it's a chunk of rock in the  Strait of Hormuz 120 kilometers from the  nearest airport in Dubai and the roads  well it might just be more pleasant to  paraglide as you go into their hajar  mountains you come up you come over and  as you to sink down to the to the resort  you've just got this breathtaking view /  / zeki bey the eco resort took five  years to build nothing happens very  quickly here it's set up to resemble a  traditional imani village but with all  the bits you'd expect from a five-star  hotel this is barefoot luxury but with a  high-end price rooms cost between eight  hundred and eighteen hundred dollars a  night private reserves 15,000 the ebay  just blends in perfectly with the  location and you know it doesn't stand  out as many other hotels do it's just  part of this uniqueness of the author  beautiful surroundings and the mountains